المال لا يهتز ، إنه يسقط ،
أحب أن أراك تذبذب في غضون
خمس سنوات فقط ، جمعت Tick Tock أكثر
من مليار مستخدم عالمي قاموا بتقطيع
جميع الخضار التي ستذهب إلى مقل
العيون حول العالم
ملتصقة بالمحتوى اللامتناهي  ومقاطع
الفيديو الفيروسية كم من الوقت تعتقد أنك تقضيه
على Tick Tock كل يوم
أه من ساعتين إلى ثلاث ساعات ثلاث إلى أربع
ساعات ولكن في الشهر الماضي حظرت حكومة الولايات المتحدة
مع أكثر من اثنتي عشرة ولاية
توك توك على معظم الأجهزة الفيدرالية
مستشهدة بمخاوف الأمن القومي
بشأنها  الشركة الأم الصينية
واحتمالية الضغط على Tick-Tock
لتسليم البيانات الشخصية
لا يوجد دليل عام على
قيام الحكومة الصينية بذلك ولكن هناك
دليل على تأثير وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الأخرى
على الصحة العقلية وخاصة
بين المراهقين من الجيل Z بدأ الاكتئاب في
الارتفاع.  بعد عام 2012 ، حدث ذلك أيضًا في إيذاء النفس
والانتحار ، كما يقول الدكتور جان توانجي ، مع
نمو الهواتف الذكية ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
تضاعف معدل الاكتئاب بين المراهقين تقريبًا بين عامي 2004 و 2019.
لذلك ، هناك
مقاطع فيديو احترافية للرسوم المتحركة ، ثم
ضربت مقاطع الفيديو الأشخاص حول كيفية قطع
أنفسهم لأن ما
تحاول الخوارزمية فعله هو حث الأشخاص على استخدام
التطبيق لفترة أطول لأن هذا هو
مقدار المال الإضافي في بيان ، قال Tick Tock في بيان
اقتبس من أحد  تتمثل أهم
الالتزامات في دعم سلامة
المراهقين ورفاههم ، ونحن ندرك أن
هذا العمل لم ينته أبدًا ، فنحن نواصل
التركيز على تدابير حماية قوية للسلامة
لمجتمعنا مع تمكين
الآباء أيضًا من خلال عناصر تحكم إضافية
لحساب المراهقين من خلال الاقتران الأسري Tick Tock
[الموسيقى  ]
أمضى مستخدمو tick tock ما معدله
ساعة ونصف يوم على التطبيق
العام الماضي أكثر من أي نظام أساسي اجتماعي آخر ،
ما الذي يجعلك تستمر في التمرير حتى
لو كنت تعلم أنه ربما قضيت
ساعتين على التطبيق مرة واحدة  شاهد مقطع الفيديو الوحيد الذي
تفضله لمشاهدة آخر ،
لذا استمر في فعل ذلك ، إنها مثل دورة
لا تدرك أن الوقت
يمر وهذا بالضبط ما حدث
لجيروم يانكي ، لقد قمت بالتأكيد طوال
الليل على Tick Tock  قبل أن أمارس
التمرير حتى شروق الشمس ،
يقول إنه فقد نومه ، فقد
عانت درجاته من الاتصال بأصدقائه ، لقد
فقد إحساسه بالذات في عام 2021 ، لقد
حذف التطبيق بعد أن أصابني بخيبة أمل من
حياتي الخاصة ليس شيئًا أريده أبدًا
أفعل بشكل خاص عندما يكون لدي
القدرة على تغييره ، لكنني لم أكن
لأنني كنت أقضي ساعات على هذا التطبيق ،
فلدينا الكثير من الموارد الرائعة
التي نقدمها لجمهورنا مجانًا ،
لكن هانا ويليامز تثبت
الجانب الإيجابي من tick tock  السماح لها بإنشاء راتب
تجاري شفاف يوفر Street Street شفافية
مدفوعة الأجر
لما يقرب من مليون متابع لها أعتقد أن Tick
Tock ساعدت بالتأكيد لمجرد أن
لديهم مثل هذا الجمهور يصل إلى الإمكانات التي
تأمل أن تعمل خوارزمية tick tock
لصالحها في مساعدة الأشخاص في
المجتمعات المهمشة هو السبب الوحيد  أنا
أفعل هذا ، إنها مهمتي بأكملها
فانيسا يوركوفيتش سي إن إن نيويورك